bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors cette potentielle
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
quel regard portez-vous de sion bonjour
d'abord c'est pas forcément un regard
qu'on porte simplement sur la
vaccination des soignants qui vont
s'interroger et je pense en tout cas que
certains sachant comme vous avez pu les
développer tout à l'heure dans votre
journal on démarche est une erreur
d'analysé et une démarche
populationnelle beaucoup plus large et
beaucoup plus général alors tout dépend
aussi dans l'expression de ce que dit ce
que dira monsieur macro lundi mais pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas forcément la
notion de ce qu'est un soignant
puisqu'un soignants normalement c'est
une personne l'individu qui est aux
proches et aux soins de la population et
des malades
mais en l'occurrence dans nos hôpitaux
il ya des personnels qui sont proches
des populations malades
il ya des personnels qui sont des
personnels techniques et des personnels
administratifs
donc nous avons encore une interrogation
pas forcément sur le fond de la faire
puisque j'ai pu le monter en tout cas la
cgt on s'est largement exprimée depuis
quelques semaines nous sommes pas
opposés à la vaccination en tant que tel
nous sommes opposés à l'obligation
vaccinale lorsque n'est pas en tout cas
adjointe d'un certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont des éléments qui permettent de
la rendre efficace efficace et surtout
acceptable vous pouvez ça on n'est pas
dans ce cadre là et on attend beaucoup
en tout cas d'intervention de chez makro
lundi pouvoir de quelle façon les choses
devraient être abonnés alors on parle
donc de loppsi 1 de l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants est-ce que
vous avez des chiffres la proportion de
soignants qui n'est pas encore vaccinés
contre locaux vides
oui eh bien nous n'avons pas réellement
de chiffres très concret puisque les
ministères en tout cas un diffuse qui
sont pas forcément les mêmes chiffres
que ça prend direction générale
l'organisation des soins diffuse donc on
a du mal à avoir réellement une vision
de ce qu'est la vaccination d'un d'un
secteur des soignants avec deux éléments
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit c'est
d'abord le ministère gère bien sûr de
façon très proche de vaccination des
soignants dans les établissements
publics qui représentent un million deux
cent mille fonctionnaires mais ne gère
pas foncer forcément une façon très
serrée la vaccination de l'établissement
privé qui à eux seuls représentent 2
millions 300 mille salariés de ces
établissements
la question c'est savoir ce qu'est une
proportion en tout cas on peut estimer
qu'il n'y a pas de niveau maximal
suffisant dans nos établissements nous
ce qu'on peut constater en tout cas dans
un établissement public c'est que nous
sommes sur des niveaux de l'acsi nation
très élevés et que nous avons rarement
entendu parler de refus de vacciner pour
des raisons x ou y
ou au contraire est une forme d'adhésion
à la vaccination qui les forme assez
largement répandue maintenant dans les
chiffres qui peuvent être éventuellement
donné par le ministère n'est pas non
plus fait qu'un d'un nombre important de
personnels hospitaliers et de personnels
techniques ou de personnel des maisons
de retraite qui sont passés par une
vaccination donc été une vaccination qui
a été dispensé dans des centres de
vaccination et non dans des lieux qui
sont des livres pour l'instant sur
lesquels en tout cas le ministère a une
vision son nombre de vaccinés possible
sur le seul pour l'instant les agressent
éventuellement éventuellement
l'assurance maladie pour ce type
d'information notamment par le biais de
l'otan se surpasse vaccinale faites donc
pas forcément pour ce caractère
obligatoire vous êtes donc pour
convaincre et non contraindre alors
comment on convint justement la
population française de se faire
vacciner
c'est un peu la question qui se pose
tous les ans lors des périodes de
pandémie de grippe
je me rappelle quand même un niveau
maximal maxi nakhlé d'animaux qui est
relativement faible et on s'aperçoit
qu'à un moment la population a un petit
peu de mal mais par le biais aussi d'une
forme de doute une forme d'interrogation
à prendre en compte de fait et tous les
ans il faut se méfier contre la grippe
donc pourquoi se convaincre parce que je
pense qu'il ya finalement assez peu de
personnel soignant qui sont réticents à
la vaccination
nous on pense qu'ils sont au contraire
très ouverts à ce type de chose ah je
vous rappelle quand même que nous avons
vécu les perdre extrêmement difficile et
que les personnels soignants qui sont à
proximité des patients ont véhiculé des
choses extrêmement difficile dans ces
derniers mois donc les mettre en
situation de quelque part de stigmatiser
comme infirmier vers en justice a rendu
dans les landes avec monsieur castex et
dire qu'à un moment c'est une
aide-soignante non vaccinés qui a
introduit le virus dans la maison de
retraite dans laquelle il exerce vous
êtes se rappeler aussi qu'il n'ya pas eu
d'essai dans cette maison de retraite
donc monsieur verront hameau exprimé sur
ce type d'éléments qui sont des
anathèmes via une profession qui était
durement touchés et c'est peut-être
aussi parce que notre profession a été
durement touchée il a été violemment mis
à contribution et surtout mise en
première ligne notamment premiers
moments de cette pandémie que
l'interrogation sont de fait de
stigmatiser nos rangs pas beaucoup plus
acceptable la volonté de souhaiter
sonnac signer
mettre une obligation c'est au contraire
à nos cinémas tease et c'est au
contraire vous remettra les coeurs et
c'est au contraire vouloir dire d'un
côté il ya les bons soignant les
mauritaniens la vraie question qui se
pose c'est de quelle façon est ce qu'on
met en situation les professionnels que
nous sommes d'avoir suffisamment
d'effectifs
lorsque nous sommes malades de pouvoir
ne pas aller au travail tout simplement
parce que nous savons comme sont à
remplacer lorsque nous avons des
symptômes c'est ne pas aller au travail
comme ça a été le cas et ça a été imposé
une personnel lors de la phase i du
cassage de la deuxième et la troisième
vague les personnels qui avait les
symptômes ont les imposer à venir au
travail donc maintenant imposer à
l'inversé la vaccination on est sûr sur
des réflexions et surtout ce soit des
mouvements politiques qui sont des
mouvements politiques qui rendent pas
forcément crédible le discours ce
gouvernement donc nous on pense que oui
la vaccination est indispensable et très
clairement indispensable dans la mise en
oeuvre cette vaccination ne doit pas
passer par une contrainte et qu'il
aboutira les sanctions mais doit passer
par un élément qui est un élément
d'arriver à convaincre et d'arrivée
surtout à exprimer un moment et a donné
la possibilité parce que je le rappelle
aussi beaucoup de nous soignons ne sont
pas encore vaccinés pourquoi parce
qu'ils n'ont pas eu l'espace temps nos
chers lorsque vous travaillez 12 heures
dans l'établissement hospitalier que
vous allez faire la queue pendant deux
heures pour aller vous faire vacciner
on n'y allait pas c'est aussi un élément
de réflexion qu'on doit avoir et
notamment qu on voit ce qu'on permet la
vaccination dans les services
d'établissement dans les services et par
l'extérieur dans les services cet
élément simplement de contraintes de
temps ne soit plus je pense qu'avant moi
cette manière de convaincre beaucoup
plus efficace tout simplement se dire on
va licencier ceux qui refusent à thaksin
est alors très rapidement
monsieur bourdillon admettons qu'elle
devienne obligatoire cette vaccination
des soignants qui refuseraient de s'y
plier seront suspendus en tout cas de
leur activité en contact avec le public
est-ce que l'hôpital alors actuelle peut
se permettre de se passer de son
personnel soignant c'est pour ça qu'on
s'estime ans est une c'est une démarche
en tout cas l'expression démagogique
ressort de la communication parce que
c'est dire à un moment on va exclure une
partie des personnels de la possibilité
d'exercer parce qu'à un moment une rampe
agne le temps mais ne serait ce le
moment de décrire la lettre publiée et
le moment où la mise en oeuvre sera
effective parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu le
temps de se vacciner les mettre en
l'écart s'est soucié de bris mais en
tout cas et supprimé une possibilité aux
hôpitaux mais aussi aux cliniques de
d'avoir des personnels sur les
personnages
les terrains notamment si la quatrième
vague arrive d'une façon assez forte
écoute et d'une façon assez difficile à
maîtriser
au sens des effectifs au sens des lits
disponibles et surtout au sens de la
possibilité dans nos établissements de
pouvoir accueillir des patients dont
j'aimais je m'interroge cet aspect
démagogique qui est un aspect en tout
cas qui laisse à penser que si l'accusé
mort finalement la quatrième vague ce
sera la faute des soldes ne sont pas
vaccinés c'est un peu fort de café
mais c'est surtout un peu comment dire
stigmatisant pour des personnels qui je
pense ça n'avait pas besoin
patrick bordés ion merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire fédéral de la cgt santé